victoire nette et précise des remparts à
domicile hier soir les bleus ont
pulvérisé mulhouse leader du classement
s'imposant 5 buts à 2 dès le premier
tiers les remparts ont multiplié les
occasions en malmenant la défense des
scorpions c'est à la 14e minute de jeu
que les efforts payent premier but
tourangeau suivi rapidement d'un
deuxième à la 16e minute
la tribune pleine à craquer et en délire
en début de saison personne n'aurait
prédit cette supériorité dans le jeu de
la part de tours
pas même le coach ôta dernier dernier à
14,11 parlons des premiers puits mais
qu'importe si ça c'est jour après jour
on l'a travaillé comme celui ci soit un
rabais de 20 mois jamais y arriver on
était jour par jour pratique par
pratiquants tellement peur qu'un
entraînement au dessus de lit confiance
à ce groupe et travailler ensemble et je
crois que c'est celle qu elles deux plus
importants dans le deuxième tiers les
remparts ont tout autant briller sans
rien lâché ils inscrivent trois nouveaux
buts et gagner leur ticket pour la
première place du classement
les deux buts inscrits par leurs
adversaires sont passés inaperçus
les tourangeaux ont su contrer presque
chaque attaque de mulhouse pour les
vainqueurs la satisfaction était totale
je pense que l'on peut pas jouer très
bien ce que c'est je pense que oui on a
vu que sur la phase aller de
championnant pouvait battre n'importe
qui ce soir on l'a encore vu bat le
leader il recevait en la gloire reçu en
france depuis le début de la saison les
remparts ont montré qu'ils avaient
toutes les capacités physiques et
mentales nécessaires pour atteindre le
haut du classement
désormais c'est chose faite il va
falloir tout mettre en oeuvre pour y
rester